[Música]
y vamos a hacer el repaso de las
noticias de la economía con danielle
hablando nada ni la otra vez un saludo
para ustedes y vamos a seguir hablando
de la que es noticia mundial de la
guerra en ucrania hoy entró en vigencia
el rublo como único medio de pago para
el gas ruso así desde angela dos días
llevamos ya hablando del tema y
seguramente lo seguiremos haciendo
durante los próximos días y es que el
kremlin ha ido explicando lo que
significa esta medida que primero
calificó de irreversible y segundo
aclaró que aplica solamente para los
países que consideran amistosos es decir
los que se aliaron para imponerles
sanciones en primer lugar el kremlin
dicen que les ofreció un mecanismo y es
que compren en euros o en dólares como
lo están haciendo actualmente pero que
abren una cuenta en gazprombank para que
éste se encargue de comprar rublos este
viernes el kremlin aclaró que no habrá
cortes inmediatos de suministro porque
el gas que se entrega hoy se paga desde
la segunda mitad de abril
y entonces que dicen en occidente pues
en europa los gobiernos ya están
analizando con sus empresas importadoras
cómo buscar mecanismos de pago aunque
hay países que todavía no se han
resignado a cumplir con esta orden japón
ya aseguro que no va a pagar ni la
moneda local rusa alemania dijo que el
kremlin tiene que respetar los contratos
existentes y también sus formas de pago
en eeuu por su parte el portavoz del
departamento de estado net price aseguró
que esta es una señal de desesperación
económica y financiera por parte de la
federación rusa dice que esto es un
reflejo de que las sanciones y los
controles de exportación entre otras
medidas económicas pues están teniendo
un impacto significativo y de otra parte
de eeuu propuso liberar reservas de
petróleo para controlar los precios
claro y es que la guerra en ucrania como
todos sabemos pues ha desencadenado en
una disparada de precios del gas natural
en europa y también del petróleo a nivel
mundial porque se teme que si los
barriles rusos salieran eventualmente
del mercado y es uno de los principales
exportadores pues habría una de
suministro por eso eeuu propuso echar
mano por tercera vez en menos de cuatro
meses de lo que llama reservas
estratégicas y liberar un millón de
barriles por día durante seis meses esto
daría un total de 180 millones de
barriles y lo dejaría por debajo del
nivel actual de 568 millones que ya era
abajo porque la capacidad es de 700
millones como vemos en el gráfico esto
quiere decir que va a quedar con un poco
menos de 400 millones de barriles
reservados al final de estos seis meses
bueno y por qué es importante este
reserva pues angela creada en los años
70 tras el embargo petrolero árabe estas
reservas son una colección de cavernas
subterráneas ubicadas en texas y
luisiana que pueden almacenar más de 700
millones de barriles de petróleo la idea
de liberar ese petróleo tiene que ver
con la oferta y la demanda pues bailén
espera que los precios bajen al liberar
estos barrios en el mercado los precios
han subido un 40% este año pero también
hay quienes creen que no se les está
dando un buen uso porque deberían ser
utilizadas cuando hay una emergencia
y no para bajar los precios
artificialmente de todas maneras un
millón de barriles también hay que
decirlo es apenas un uno por ciento de
lo que consume el mundo todos los días
es decir no hacemos mucho y bueno
daniela cómo llega la economía de costa
rica- las elecciones de este domingo ya
pasando nos para temas latinoamericanos
la loca sí pues la estabilidad
financiera principalmente y también la
lucha contra el desempleo son como en
toda elección en américa latina
principalmente los retos a los que se
enfrenta quienquiera que sea elegido
nuevo presidente de costa rica sobre el
panorama económico pues vamos a ver las
cifras costa rica viene reduciendo
drásticamente una tasa de desempleo que
en el peor año de la pandemia saltó al
24% la tasa de pobreza sigue más alta
que antes de la pandemia con un 23 por
ciento también está en juego el destino
de un acuerdo financiero con el fondo
monetario internacional por casi 1.800
millones de dólares y es que a pesar de
que los desembolsos ya están
garantizados pues el país tiene que
comprometerse a cumplir con unas reglas
fiscales bastante estrictas que por lo
general son muy impopulares
tanto el exministro de hacienda rodrigo
chávez como su contrincante de segunda
ronda josé maría figueres difieren en
ciertos puntos e incluso plantean que
pueden renegociar este acuerdo muy bien
en daniela pues él le agradezco a
ustedes por la información y vamos a
continuar con más noticias ahora es
momento de ir a directo países